so it's time to add some scenery to this
coaster and I have nothing to say you
really so let's just start this
light is not enough
sunlight begins to fade now and I feel
like I'm losing time but I don't know
how I'm here sunlight is turned to gray
and I feel come lose in love
again I don't know how
and feels
you're looking
do that
you that I wanted need
and our dating although the world we
build the slipping through our fingers
running out of time
I've chosen
and I wore lace down
we hide in prison
camellia
feel sorry you're looking
I can feel you
this is young
and it's you that I wanna breathe but
it's you it's you that I wanted me
okay so that's it for now I've got quite
a lot of paths worked on in this little
restaurant kind of building and then
there's this little flat right I what's
it called again something but it's cool
and it spins and it's fast and cool and
stuff so um yeah that's uh that's
awesome
so next episode I'm going to finish this
that's some more paths in here well I've
already planted them but make them nice
right now they're nothing and maybe add
a little flat right madhouse kind of
thing in there and I know I don't think
I can fill an entire episode with just
that so I might as well start working on
this part of the park as well and then
after I finished that and maybe added
the foliage I will see if I can if my
computer allows me to do that at a
little bit of Park section in here as
well with a coaster or something but I'm
not sure about that because my PC is
crappy and it probably won't allow
anything beyond whatever shitty things
it can handle so um yeah that's all for
next time see you then